I think that the whole thing about
Gurren Lagann is that it's a really fun
series to watch but you can't listen to
what they're trying to tell you now it
just doesn't make sense
I remember it was something like spiral
energy evolution is like a spiral cuz
spiral is like a DNA and that was those
my galloping spins it spins in a spiral
I don't understand but the writers were
just like holy [ __ ] guys we're so
[ __ ] smart yeah nothing bad that's
not what they did
what happens was this on candy cane and
they're like dude spiral energy never
know that they were [ __ ] smoking weed
or something probably weird
they are gonna that's gonna
conversationally having your hi could
you just like dude dude then well one
thing goes guys are [ __ ] figured it
out guys spirals viral
[ __ ] the meaning of life is [ __ ]
spirals and on that lower weight but if
spirals if spirals dude dude dude do if
spirals dude spirals are the good guys
was the bad guys dude i spirals i do
what your own like a [ __ ] winner what
what if the bad guys were like we're
like a straight line and it goes it's
like not a spiral no not straight line
boxes oh do you remember the way what if
whenever the enemies exploded they
dropped shapes
oh dude uh doing the shapes room and the
shapes were bombs I do you know what we
need
do you know what like a spar was like
it's like a drill man si oh no no guys
guys you know what we need
titties whoa yo cool it now
one second I need to get a drink who the
hell do you think I am let you get it
come on
let you get a drink let me let you get a
drink
hey take a [ __ ] sick chicken take a
[ __ ] flip put it on your lips Provo
put it on the lips I don't know any of
these people think go take a piss done
the things I take a piss
what are you [ __ ] Bear Grylls are you
just drinking your piss oh and go take a
piss because like you know what I said
i'ma drink my piss i'ma drink my piss
welcome to car talk to everyone I have a
question for you okay look at your boy
she's here right now she's on a roll
okay mmm genius roll out it's super tame
useful apps Holden use harden it was
super effective team this flash Holden
uses pullout Jeannie is a slack a [ __ ]
highly effective Holden has fainted all
the uses hydro pump
Holden Jesus harden again I'd your pump
hold it did it did anyone did anyone do
this when them in a random tangent
whenever you caught a metapod and you
could name it whatever you want
was anyone immature like me and a
nerdiness then it would use like penis
use harden oh my god Lauren
I knew you were such in a league all on
your own as a child [ __ ] know man use
a [ __ ] immature now no but sitting
here face if I was getting some ether
attacks I would do like Holden uses
pound and compete like geniuses swallow
and gene gene uses like dirty trick or
bite and I like Holden uses hydro pump
Jin uses power blow oh my god oh my god
I'm using
bulrush gene ask your [ __ ] question
before this goes genie has escaped
what ask your question I games I just
can't escape I just came to left foot
regardless darn what's your question
what hey what do i do I have to use the
[ __ ] heal now no cuz you know why why
all we had was a burn heal and we used
it on Jean Oh